[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونرصد معكم اخر المستجدات
الى العناوين
زعيم وفاجنر يحذروا من نقص الذخيره في
بخموت ويحمل القاده الروس المسؤوليه في
ماريوبل
حاله تسمم جديده بين طالبات ايرانيات في
عشرات المدارس والسلطات تعتقل صحفيا كشف
الكارثه
الشرطه الباكستانيه تعلن مقتل تسعه من
افرادها واصابات خطيره في انفجار جنوب غرب
البلاد
وسط تصاعد التوترات مع بيكين وزير الدفاع
التايواني يحذروا من هجوم مفاجئ للجيش
الصيني
البدايه من تطورات المعارك الطاحنه التي
تشهدها مدينه باخمه الاوكرانيه حيث تواصل
القوات الروسيه جهودها لتطويق مدينه
باخموت التي تشكل رمزا ومركزا للحرب في
الشرق الاوكراني من جانبه اعلن الجيش
الروسي عن استهداف كتيبه اوكرانيه فيزا
بوريجيا في جنوب شرق اوكرانيا وقال مؤسس
مجموعه فاغنر الروسيه ان قواته التي تشدد
قبضتها الان على مدينه بخموت الاوكرانيه
لا تحصل على احتياجاتها من الذخيره واذا
اجبرت على التراجع ستنهار هذه الجبهه
باكملها شكى ايضا من ان معظم الذخيره التي
وعدت بها موسكو قواته في فبراير لم يتم
شحنها بعد وقال بريكوجين على قناه
تيليجرام في الوقت الحالي نحاولوا معرفه
السبب هل هي مجرد بيروقراطيه عاديه ام
خيانه
اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بيلو قرود الروسيه في
بلادكوف عن اسقاط القوات ثلاثه صواريخ في
مدينه نوفي اوسكول وبحسب حاكم المقاطعه لم
يصب سوى شخص واحد بشظايا هذه المنطقه
بجنوب روسيا تحديدا قرب منطقه الاوكرانيه
في حين تضررت واجهات المباني وخطوط
الكهرباء في عده قرى بسبب الشظايا واشار
الى ان جميع فرق الطوارئ توجهت الى مكان
الحادثه واعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
التصدي لاكثر من 95 هجوما روسيا خلال 24
ساعه في خمسه مناطق وقالت في بيان لها ان
القوات الروسيه لا تزال تواصل هجماتها في
محاور كوبيانسك وبخموت
ولمانسك وشنت 27 غاره جويه و70 هجوما
صاروخيا يوم امس واشارت الاركان
الاوكرانيه الى ان قوتها الجويه شنت 12
غاره على واقع تمركزت فيها القوات الروسيه
وانتشرت فيها ومع ازدياد معارك ضخمه شراسه
تتضاءى الفرص كيا في ابقاء المدينه شبه
المحاصره تحت سيطرتها رغم المقاومه الشرسه
لمن تبقى من الجيش في مواجهه قوه موسكو
حيث يتبقى سيناريوهان يحكمان مصير هذه
المدينه
هذه الصور وهذه نصر وهزيمه وشكان لم يدك
فيها بعد من الغالب ومن المغلوب لكن
الحديث اليوم عن تضاؤل فرص المقاومين
الاوكرانيين في باخموت
المعركه في المدينه منذ اغسطس الماضي
ووفقا لاخر المعلومات تبدو قريبه
بالنهايتها نهايه لا يريد كلا المتحاربين
الخروج منها مهزومه
سيناريوهان ثالث لهما امامك في اما
الانسحاب خلصت بعد تدمير الجسور والطرق
لكسب الوقت وابطاء القوات الروسيه ومنعها
من التوجه غربا في العمق الاوكراني او
الانتظار حتى الاستسلام لكن هذا الخيار قد
ينتهي بكارثه عسكريه بالنسبه الى القوات
المدافعه عن المدينه
بالمقابل تعمل روسيا على قطع الامدادات عن
القوات الاوكرانيه في قلب المدينه وضرب
طوق كامل حولها المقاومه الاوكرانيه
المستمره منذ ثمانيه اشهر استنزفت الكثير
من قدرات القوات المهاجمه حيث تسعى
لانسحاب محكم وبشروط هي من يسوعها على ارض
المعركه
خلال الهجوم يتقدمون في مجموعات من خمسه
او عشرين عنصرا نحن نبدو لقصار جهدنا
لضربهم هناك الكثير منهم ماتوا وجثثهم
منتشره في جميع انحاء الميدان بين ترقب
للنصر وهزيم في باخموت قد تكون الساعات
القادمه حبلى بالمفاجات مفاجات قد تاتي
بانتصار رمزي انتظرته موسكو طويلا وهزيمه
لا تريدها كييف وان كانت بطعم النصر
وانضم الينا
حذيفه عادل وايضا من دنيات رائد الاغبر
مراسل العربيه اهلا بكما ابدا معك رائد
يعني اخر التطورات الميدانيه في دانياسك
في ظل اتهامات قويه وجهها مؤسس فاجنر
للقوات الروسيه من ناحيه عدم امداد فريقه
يعني مجموعته
بالذخيره التي كانت مطلوبه وايضا بانه
اعاقه وصول اشخاص انضموا حديثا اليه هذه
الاتهامات كيف تؤثر على المعارك على الارض
حسب رصدقه
صباح صباح الخير راويه بالفعل هناك
تصريحات
مستمره من قبل مؤسس قوات فاغنر يفقينيا
بروجيجن
يتهم فيها الدفاع الروسيه بالتقصير
بالامدادات العسكريه ان كان البشريه او
حتى
الامداد بالذخيره لكن حقيقه هنا في محور
عشرات الالاف من القذائف والصواريخ
المتنوعه تطلق بشكل يومي على مواقع القوات
الاوكرانيه المتمركزه في عده محاور ربما
يكون
يطلب اسلحه يعني بنوع
خصيصا او معين وترفض الدفاع الروسيه
امدادوا بهذا النوع لانه يكون ممنوع دوليا
او يعني غير متواجد ما بين ايدي الدفاع
بالفعل المعارك مستمره وقويه وتشهد شراسه
كبيره على جميع المحاور ان كان افديف
كمارنكا
هذه المعارك تشهد تقدم للقوات الروسيه
وضخمه اهم النقاط ايضا تتقدم فيها قوات
فاغنر كل هذا التقدم ينتظر انجاز كامل
بالسيطره على احدى المدن كما كان في
سوليدار على سبيل المثال وهذا ما يتوق
اليه جانب الروسي في ذات الوقت تدافع
اوكرانيا عن مدينه باخموت لدرجه ان توقف
الانتصارات الروسيه المتكرره منذ انطلاق
هذا العام بالفعل هناك اسلحه متطوره وصلت
الى سيدي
هنا في دنيتك ولكن دعني اشرك الزميل حذيفه
عادل معنا لنرى الجانب الرسمي الاوكراني
وما يحكى عن تاهب اوكراني بما يخص يعني
مخافه من هجوم صاروخي محتمل على العاصمه
كيف ما صحه هذه المعلومات
طيب صباح الخير راويه في الحقيقه عمليه
الهجوم وحاله التاهب الجوي هي مستمره في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه سواء كان في العاصمه
او في المدن الاخرى كانت قد اطلقت القوات
الروسيه في الليله الماضيه خمسه عشر طائره
مسيره من تراث شاهد نحو مناطق مختلفه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه استطاع الدفاع الجوي
الاوكراني ان يسقط 13 طائره منها وطائرتين
اصابتا اهدافهما هنا في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه هذا من جانب اما عمليه التاهب
من ومخافه اطلاق الصواريخ كما تقول نتاليا
وهي ناطق الرسمي باسم القوات القياده
العملياتيه في الجنوب تقول ان حركه السفن
وحركه الخواصات في البحر الاسود للجيش
الروسي تنذر بان هنالك يعني استعداد
لعمليه استهداف ولكن طبعا هم يؤكدون ايضا
ان عمليه استهداف واسعه النطاق التي كانت
في السابق الاتحاد الروسي غير قادر عليها
لانه غير قادر على عمليه الانتاج لهذه
الصواريخ بالسرعه المطلوبه وايضا هي مكلفه
جدا لذلك الان تغير التكتيكات الاتحاد
الروسي اصبح يطلق الطائرات المسيره لارباك
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني ومن بعد ذلك يقوم
باستهدافات في مناطق محدده وحتى هذه
اللحظه يقولون ان الدفاع الجوي عن اوكراني
اصبح بكفاءه عاليه قادره على اسقاط معظم
الضربات التي توجه نحو الاراضي الاوكرانيه
والامر الذي كما يقولون فشل في تدمير نظام
الطاقه الاوكراني وها نحن نخرج الان
تقريبا من نظام التدفئه
للشتاء ويقولون انهم يخرجون منه بوضع جيد
اما فيما يخص الوضع في باخ متراويه هي
مدينه صغيره جدا طبعا عمليه اطلاق القذائف
والصواريخ كما تقول القوات الاوكرانيه
انها محدوده جدا خاصه ان الاتحاد الروسي
اصبح يعني قد بدات تنفذ هذا ما تقوله
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه لذلك
اصبح يعمل بشكل اكبر براجمات الصواريخ
وبالمدفعيه والامر الذي يدمر المدينه بشكل
كامل ولكن عمليات هجوم محدده وموجهه هي في
ثلاثه
هل هناك من تلميح ربما اوكرانيا على
احتماليه انسحاب القوات الاوكرانيه من
باخموت يعني ان كانت المعركه ليست لصالحهم
نعم راويه في الحقيقه طبعا عمليه الانسحاب
في المعارك هي امر لابد ان يوضع في
الاعتبار وهذا ما تقوله القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه اطلاقا لن
تصدر اي اوامر باي عمليه انسحاب تقول
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وقد اكد قائد
القوات في الشرق ان ما زالت دفاعات القوات
الاوكرانيه متينه وانهم قادرين على الحفاظ
على المدينه هذه العمليات التي تتم من قبل
الاتحاد الروسي كما يقولون هي في الضواحي
لم تسجل اي عمليه اختراق لدفاعات الجيش
الاوكراني والدخول الى داخل المدينه الامر
الذي طبعا يروج الاتحاد الروسي كما يقولون
في دعايه انهم استطاعوا ان يدخلوا الى
داخل المدينه المحاور ثلاثه مارينكا
بينهما هنالك محور ساخن جدا تحاول القوات
الروسيه اختراق الدفاعات هناك ولكنها لم
تنجح حتى الان كذلك
من اتجاه الشمال ايضا هنالك محاوله للدخول
وكذلك منطقه يعني غرب غربها قليلا هنالك
مقدارا ايضا تحاول القوات الروسيه منه
الولوج والد الى داخل المدينه ولكنها حتى
هذه اللحظه تفشل تقول ايضا القوات
الاوكرانيه ان الجهه الغربيه تحت سيطرتهم
بالكامل على الرغم من قصف الجسر الذي كان
عن طريقه بشكل سهل يمكن هنالك طرق ترابيه
بديله يمكن من خلالها ادخال الاعدادات
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه انتقل الى رائد
كنا نتحدث عن الاسلحه المستخدمه وكاله ان
نيوز نقلت عن مصادر اوكرانيا ان الجيش
الروسي لاول مره استخدم قنابل من طراز اي
بي او اب اي بي 1500 وهي ذات قدرات
تدميريه عاليه تحديدا بافديافكا هل من
معلومات حول اللجوء الى هذه
القناه بالخطيره
يعني راويه انا ابدا من حيث انتهى زميلي
حذيفه حيث ان محوري مار كوافديفكا وما
بينهما تشهد هذه المنطقه زخما كبيرا
بالاعمال العسكريه خاصه من الجانب الروسي
الذي ادخل في اطار العمليه العسكريه اسلحه
متطوره وحديثه عدا عن التي كان يستخدمها
مع انطلاق العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا حيث كانت تستخدم الاسلحه
السوفييتيه وما كان يعني حاضرا في
المستودعات مستودعات الذخيره لكن اليوم
باتت الدفاع الروسيه تدخل المقاتلات
المتطوره الحديثه لم يكن سلاح الجو يعمل
بقوه خلال العام الماضي لكن اليوم نشهد
حضورا كبيرا للمقاتلات الروسيه في سماء
المنطقه ايضا هناك دبابات
تسعون هذه الدبابات هي الاكثر تطورا من
التي كانت تستخدم في الاعمال العسكريه
دخلت ايضا مطلع هذا العام في اطار العمليه
العسكريه لكن بخصوص القنابل التي تحدثت
عنها بالفعل كتبت وسائل اعلام غربيه وايضا
هنا محليه غير رسميه هذه الانباء بالفعل
غير رسميه لكن الحديث عن قنابل تزن كل
قنبله
1500 كيلوغرام تدعى او تسمى قنابل
انزلاقيه ضربت في منطقه افديفكا حسب
المصادر التي كتبت عن هذا الخبر وانها
تحدث تدميرا كبيرا وتلحق ضررا كبيرا
بالقوات الاوكرانيه المتمركزه في افديفيكا
ولم تستطع القوات الروسيه تحطيم صمود هذه
القوات الاوكرانيه في ذلك المحور ما زالت
المعارك مستعره بالفعل مع ادخال انواع
حديثه من المدافع ومن راجمات الصواريخ كنا
نسمع اصوات تقليديه نميز ما بين سقوط
القذيفه واطلاق الصاروخ راويه اليوم بتنا
لا نميز الاختلاف نوع الصوت وذلك لاختلاف
انواع المدافع والاسلحه التي باتت
تستخدمها القوات الروسيه وهي حديثه حسب
الدفاع الروسيه مراسله للعربيه حذيفه عادل
ورائد الاغبر شكرا جزيلا لكما
ويتصاعد التوتر بين بولندا والمانيا بشان
التسليح اوكرانيا بدبابات وقطع الغيار
الخاصه بها حيث تتهم عرسو جارتها برلين
بالتقاعسي في ارسال الدبابات الى الجبهات
الاوكرانيه
في الباحه الخلفيه لاوكرانيا يتصاعد توتر
قد يهدد جبهتها المشتعله مع روسيا بعدما
حققت تقدما ملحوظا في استعاده اراضيها
بدعم غربي التهديد ياتي بسبب الخلافات بين
المانيا وبولندا بشان تزويد كييف بالاسلحه
حيث تتهم وارسو برلين بالتقاعس في ارسال
الدبابات الى الاوكرانيين حتى وصل الامر
بوارسو للتهديد بارسال دبابات المانيه الى
جبهات دون موافقه برلين المانيا كانت اعطت
الضوء الاخضر بارسال عدد محدود من دبابات
لوبارد لكن البولنديين يقولون ان نموذج
الاقدم الذي التزموا بارساله سيكون محدود
الاستخدام دون قطع غيار المسؤوليه
الرئيسيه تقع على عاتق المانيا المنتج
الرئيسي لتلك الدبابات
كنا نحط الجانب الالماني منذ فتره طويله
على الانضمام الى التحالف وليس فقط تسليم
الدبابات وقطع الغيار ايضا الخلاف بين
البلدين ليس جديدا اذ تحيي وارسو مطالبها
مرارا بالتعويض عما تكبدته منذ ايام
الاجتياح النازي لاراضيها تعويض تقول انه
يبلغ تريليونا وثلاثه مليارات دولار
المانيا اعتبرت نبره جارتها الحاده ليست
الا مسرحا سياسيا قبل الانتخابات المقبله
وستزول مع نهايه الانتخابات التي تكلف
الحزب الحاكمه قبضته في البلاد
نشرتنا مستمره فيها بعض الفاصل رغم
التنديد الدولي لقرار طالبان اعاده فتح
الجامعات الافغانيه
والفتيات لا يزالن محظ
ورات
اهلا بكم من جديد يعقد اليوم مجلس محافظي
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه اجتماعا في
فيينا لاجراء مناقشات حول تعزيز انشطه
الوكاله المتعلقه بالسلامه النوويه
والعلوم والتكنولوجيا والتطبيقات وستشمل
المباحثات ايضا وفقا للتوقعات مراقبه
المنشات النوويه في ايران والاشراف على
الانشطه النوويه في كوريا الشماليه
بالاضافه الى قضايا الامن والضمانات في
محطه الطاقه النوويه
الخاضعه للسيطره الروسيه ومن فيينا تنضم
الينا مفرده العربيه راغده بهنام اهلا بك
راغده يعني طبعا هذا الاجتماع ياتي في وسط
التوتر متصاعد بين الغرب وايران ماذا في
اولويه اجنده هذا الاجتماع
اهلا بك يعني من دون شك ايران الملف
النووي الايراني سيكون يعني سياخذ حيز
كبير من هذه الاجتماعات كما كل مره ربما
ولكن هذه المره لانه كانت هناك تقارير
وتحدثت عنها الوكاله عن العثور على اثار
يوراني ومخصب تصل نقاوته الى نسبه 84% هي
نسبه قريبه جدا من 90 بالمئه اللازمه
لانتاج سلاح نووي لذلك يعني هذا الملف من
دون شك يعني سيتم مناقشته في جزئين الجزء
الاول المتعلق بالتزامات ايران ضمن
اتفاقيه حظر انتشار الاسلحه النوويه وهذا
كان يعني محل زياره رفيع الجروسسي امين
عام الوكاله الى طهران قبل يومين هو عاد
يوم السبت ليلا ليعلن بانه تم التوصل
لاتفاقات مع ايران لحل مساله المواقع
السريه التي كانت يعني عالقه بين الوكاله
او ما زالت عالقه بين الوكاله وايران منذ
سنوات في الواقع يعني وايضا قال بانه
سيكون هناك خطوات يعني تم الاتفاق عليها
خطوات يعني فعليه على الارض في الاسابيع
المقبله ولكن يعني هناك غموض حول هذه
الخطوات لانه الجانب الايراني يعني استرا
ربما تصريحات متناقده مع كلام جروس قال
بانه يعني عكس ما كان اعلن جروستي بانه
سيتم اعاده تثبيت كاميرات المراقبه كان
هناك تصريحات ايرانيه تقول بانه لن يتم
تثبيت اي كاميرات يعني ضمن الاتفاق النووي
ولكن سنلتزم فقط بالتزاماتنا ضمن اتفاقيه
حظر تطبيق انتشار الاسلحه النوويه لذلك
هناك بعض اللغات حول ما تم الاتفاق عليه
حول ما اعلنه غروستي وما اعلنه الطرف
الايراني ربما جراسه يوضح هذا اللغط يعني
اليوم لانه يعني سيعلن انطلاق اعمال مجلس
المحافظين بمؤتمر صحفي ظهرا تقريبا وهو
سيرفع او رفع تقريرين للمجلس حول التزامات
ايران النوويه واحده ضمن يعني الاتفاق
العمل 2015 واحده ضمن اتفاق حظر انتشار
الاس لذلك ايضا يعني هناك ترقب لنعرف ما
اذا كانت الدول الغربيه
ستقرر التصعيد مره ثالثه يعني في اقل من
عام او في خلال عام وتطرح يعني مشروع قرار
يدين ايران كذلك ويدعوها للتعاون هذا
الامر ما زال غير واضح ربما الدول الغربيه
تحاول تجنب يعني طرحها كذا مشروع هذه
المره اذا ما كان بالفعل جرس ابلغ المجلس
بانه هناك تقدم في هذه المشاورات التقنيه
مع ايران راغده يعني نتائج اجتماع مجلس
المحافظين اليوم هل ان كانت ايجابيه هي
ستمهد لعوده مفاوضات الاتفاق النووي لانه
كان هناك موقف للخارجيه الايرانيه منذ
قليل اعتبرت فيه ان زياره جروسيه كانت جزء
من الجهود المبذوله لعوده كافه الاطراف
الى طاوله الحوار
يعني بحسب ما يعني لو كان هناك فعلا تعاون
ولكن يعني هذا الامر لم يظهر خلال يوم او
يومين لانه ما سالت المواقع النوويه
السريه يعني هي واحده من المسائل العالقه
والتي تعرقل توقيع الاتفاق النووي لو تم
حلها وهذا الامر لم يحصل خلال ايام لانه
ما زال هناك شكوك حول مدى اراده ايران
فعلا للتجاوب مع جروسين حتى ولو حصل على
وعود الوعود شيء يعني والتصرف والافعال هي
شيء مختلف لذلك يعني هذه نقطه ولكن الدول
الغربيه اصلا الان تقول بانها غير مستعده
للعوده لهذه المفاوضات او التوقيع بالفعل
على اتفاق النووي الان يعني دي اسباب اخرى
متعلقه بدعم ايران لروسيا عسكريا في الحرب
في اوكرانيا وايضا متعلقه بقمع الاحتجاجات
هناك لذلك لو تم حل هذه المساله هي مساله
المواقع النوويه لن يتم حلها خلال ايام هي
مساله ستستغرق اسابيع ويجب على ايران ان
تثبت حسي وتقدم اجوبه تكون مقبوله من
الوكاله وتعلن الوكاله بعدها بانه حصلت
على الاجوبه التي تريدها لذلك نوايا ايران
هنا ما زالت محل شك ما زالت الدول الغربيه
يعني تعمل على تقييم نوايا ايران من ناحيه
التعاون حول هذه المواقع لذلك اعمال هذا
المجلس الذي تستمر طوال هذا الاسبوع
ستناقش يعني زياره بروسلي وما تقدمت له من
وعود من الطرف الايراني ولكن لن تكون هناك
اجوبه يعني جذريه محدده يعني ربما تفتح
الطريق كما يعني يقول الطرف الايراني
لاعاده او للعوده لهذه المفاوضات الان
شكرا جزيلا لك من فيانا مفاده العربيه
راغبه
اعتقلت السلطات الامنيه الايرانيه في
محافظه يقوم بواسطه ايران رئيسه تحرير
موقع كوم نيوز الاخباري الصحفيه علي بور
طبطبائي بعدما كشف للمره الاولى عن حالات
تسميم الطالبات في المحافظه بحسب ما نشر
موقع اعتماد اون لاين الاصلاحي وذلك بعد
نشر طبطبائي الذي ينشط في تويتر باسم
خيزران تقارير حول هذه الظاهره التي بدات
في الثلاثين من نوفمبر ومتابعتها مع
انتشار حالات جديده لاسيما في المكان
الاول الذي ظهرت فيه واعتبرت صحف المعارضه
ان اعتقال الصحفيين يعد بمثابه ضغط على
الاعلام لعدم كشف حقيقه الازمه واكدت
احصاءات قناه ايران انترناشونال ان 80
مدرسه على الاقل تواجه ازمه تسمم بسبب
تعرض طالباتها لهجوم كيماوي وسط اهمال بعض
المدارس تقديم مساعدات لازمه التلميذات
وبعد التحقق من مقاطع الفيديو يبدو ان
رقعه الارهاب البيولوجي تتسع كما نشاهد في
هذه الخريطه حيث شملت محافظه طهران
العاصمه الارستان خرسان الرضويه فارس
واصفهان
واردبيل وهمزان واذربيجان الشرقيه وايضا
الغربيه في الاعلى في السياق قالت رئيسه
مركز الصحه غرب الاهواز انه ظهرت على
التلميذات اعراض مثل احمرار الوجه والبشره
وضيق التنفس ومن جهته اشار نائب رئيس
جامعه الاحواز للعلوم الطبيه الى ارتفاعي
حصيله المتسممات في مدرسه خيام حيث تسممت
40 تلميذ على الاقل 10 منهن تحت تم السماح
لهن بمغادره المستشفى ننوه قبل المتابعه
الى الاخبار العاجله التي وردت قبل قليل
نقلا عن خامنئي الذي اتهم جونات
لانهم
المسؤولين عن جريمه تسميم الطالبات
واقر بانها جريمه لا تختفر
نتابع وطلبه المتحدثه الرسميه باسم مفوضيه
الامم المتحده الساميه لحقوق الانسان
رافيندا شمتساني بطاقات الحقائق للتعرف
على مرتكبي هذه الهجمات الكيماويه
ومعاقبتهم خاصه وان قضيه التسمم المتسلل
للفتيات ارتبطت بالجغرافيا السياسيه
لايران وامتدت الى عده مدن على حد تعبيرها
[موسيقى]
ودعت مجموعه من الناشطات الايرانيات الى
التظاهر في الشوارع في يوم المراه العالمي
الذي يصادف الثامن من مارس وذلك للاحتجاج
على ما وصف بالهجمات الكيماويه على مدارس
التلميذات في ايران وجاء في الدعوه التي
وقعتها عدد من الناشطات في ايران نطلب من
الجميع ولا سيما الناشطين والناشطات
والعمال والطلاب الانضمام الى هذا
الاحتجاج والدفاع عن الاطفال وحقوق
الفتيات والنساء
وصف الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي ظاهره
تسمم طالبات المدارس في البلاد بانها
مؤامره ونقلت وكاله ارنا الرسميه عن رئيس
قوله الى تصميم الطالبات يشكل حلقه اخرى
من سلسله ما اسماها بالمؤامرات التي
يحوقها الاعداء بهدف اثاره التوتر
والتهويل داخل المجتمع ونشر الخوف
اجتبك اولياء امور الطالبات اللواتي
تعرضنا للتسمم مع قوات الشرطه والحرس
الثوري الايراني وذلك خلال تجمع للاهالي
امام احد المستشفيات في مدينه رامز شرقي
الاهوس نتابع
[موسيقى]
وفي سياق اخر اعلنت محكمه ايرانيه في
مدينه الاحواز حكما بالاعدام على سته
اعضاء ينتمون لحركه نضال العربي لتحرير
الاحواس وبحسب وكاله تسنيم الايرانيه
اتهمت المحكمه الاشخاص السته بتنفيذ
عمليات مسلحه تسببت بمقتل اربعه عناصر امن
ايرانيه منهم اثنين من عناصر البسيج في
مدينه عبادان الواقعه جنوب غرب الاحواز
يدخل الملف الرهينه البلجيكي المعتقل في
ايران مشاهدينا اوليفيي
والدبلوماسي الايراني المعتقل في بلجيكا
على خلفيه مخطط ارهابي فاشل اسابيع حاسمه
بعد تاكيد المحكمه الدستوريه البلجيكيه
على دستوريه المعاهده المبرمه مع ايران
حول تبادل السجناء وتوصيتها الى الحكومه
بواجب ابلاغ ضحايا المخطط الارهابي بصفه
مسبقه قبل تسليم اسد الله اسدي الى بلاده
رفض المحكمه الدستوريه البلجيكيه طلب
الغاء المعاهده المبرمه مع ايران حول
تبادل السجناء يفتح الباب امام امكانيه
عوده الرهينه
البلجيكيل المعتقل في ايران في مقابل
افراج بلجيكا عن الدبلوماسيه الايراني اسد
الله اسد المعتقل لديها افق يظل معقدا رغم
قرار اعلى هيئه قضائيه في البلاد سينيك
انها المره الثالثه التي تتخذ فيها
المحكمه الدستوريه قرارا يتناقض مع قرارها
الاول حيث علقت تنفيذ المعاهده في مرحله
اولى كان القرار مفاجئا نسبيا هذا الملف
يشهد التطورات استثنائيه واعتقد ان
المحكمه لم تتجاهل ضغط الراي العام لكنها
توصلت الى قرار متوازن
المحكمه الدستوريه رفضت طلب الغاء
المعاهده الذي قدمه ممثلون معارضه
الايرانيه قرار يمكن الحكومه البلجيكيه من
التمهيد الاجرائي لتنفيذ المعاهده
القرار يامر ايضا للحكومه البلجيكيه
بابلاغ ضحايا المخطط الارهابي الفاشلي قبل
الافراج عن الدبلوماسي المعتقل كي يتمكنوا
من التظلم امام المحكمه الابتدائيه
اذا خسرنا القضيه امام المحكمه الابتدائيه
وقمنا بالطعن في قرارها امام محكمه
الاستئناف فان ذلك لا يمنع الحكومه من
تبادل السجناء اما اذا خسرت الحكومه وطعنت
في قرار المحكمه الابتدائيه فلا يمكنها في
الوقت نفسه تنفيذ المعاهده بحكم وجود قرار
قضائي
امام الحكومه البلجيكيه اسابيع قليله
لتبادل وثيقه المعاهده الرسميه مع الجانب
الايراني حيث يستخدم الرهينه البلجيكي
ورقه مقايضه لاستعاده اسد الله اسدي ملف
معقد تداعياته تتجاوز حتما نطاقا العلاقات
الثنائيه بين بلجك وايران قرار المحكمه
الدستوريه يعكس الحرسه على انقاذ حياه
الرهينه البلجيكيه
من سجنه الايراني دون ان يتجاهل حقوق
ضحايا المخطط الارهابيه الفاشل الذي قاده
اسد الله اسد المعتقل في بلجيكا قرار لا
يحسم المعركه القانونيه بين الجانبين
نور الدين الفريد العربيه بروكسي
افغانستان الى صوف في الدراسه بعد مرور
عطله الشتاء لكن ارتيادها بالنسبه للنساء
ما يزال محظورا منذ عوده طالبان الى سده
الحكم في اغسطس قبل عامين وفرض الطالبان
التي لم تتلقى اي اعتراف رسمي بحكومتها
الحضره بعد اتهام الطالبات او الطالبات
بتجاهل قواعد اللباس الصارمه واشتراط ان
يرافقن قريب ذكر والى الحرم الجامعي قال
المبعوث الخاص للاتحاد الاوروبي الى
افغانستان توماس نيكلسون انه لم يسمع اي
التزام واضح من وزراء طالبان مؤكدا انهم
لم يتعهدوا باعاده فتح المدارس والجامعات
للفتيات خلال العام الدراسي الجديد ومن
كابول ينضم الينا من هناك مراسل العربيه
عبد الله نادر اهلا بك عبد الله
الذكور الرجال عادوا الى الجامعات في
افغانستان ولكن فعليا شكرا ولكن فعليا
الاناث لم يعودوا حتى الان ما وقع عوده
عوده الذكور الى الجامعات وهل هنالك من
ضغوط ربما
تمارس الان على طالبان شعبيه من الجمعيات
الحقيقيه النسائيه
نعم لقد توجه البنين والشباب الى الجامعات
صباح اليوم الى الجامعات الحكوميه
والاهليه دون الفتيات والبنات وهذه
العمليه التعليميه كان من المتوقع ان تحضر
او ان تتوجه كذلك الفتيات في هذه في هذا
هذا العام الجديد الى الجامعات والمدارس
ولكن لا يبدو او لا يظهر هناك اي شارده
لفتح الجامعات والمدارس فوق الصف السادس
الابتدائي امام الفتيات والبنات وطالبان
تبرر بانها بصدد وضع اليه ووضع يعني مناهج
تعليميه خاصه
للفتيات والبنات ولكن الامر وضع هذه
المناهج واليه التعليميه للفتيات والبنات
استغرقت اكثر من 18 الشهر مايساوي 130
يوما وبالتالي الاوساط التعليميه
الافغانيه
غاضبون عن هذا
هذا ايقاف ايقاف الجامعات والمدارس امام
الفتيات الضغوط الضغوطات الخارجيه
والداخليه لم تؤثر على طالبان لحد الان
فقد كانت هناك يعني لقاءات ومناقشات
ومباحثات مع مسؤولي طالبان من جهه اطراف
دوليه بما فيها الامميه وكان اخر هذه
المناقشات والمباحثات لممثل الخاص للاتحاد
الاوروبي توماس نيكل الذي ظهر امس الاحد
في مؤتمر صحفي هنا
واشار الى انه التقى بمسؤوليه من طالبان
وناقشه مع هؤلاء
فتح اعاده اعاده الفتح ابواب الجامعات
والمدارس امام الفتيات ولكن لم يسمع منهم
اي التزام حيال فتح هذه المدارس والجامعات
امام الفتيات وهذا يعني ان طالبان لحد
الان ليس لديها اي عمليه او اي اليه
وخطه بفتح الجامعات المدارس للفتيات
والبنات
وطلبان تقول انه المشكله بالنسبه لها هي
ان اللباس غير محتشم وشرط اخر الذي هو
مرافقه ذكر مع الفتاه للذهاب الى المدرسه
او حتى الى الجامعه يعني هل هنالك من اليه
وضعت لتنفيذ هذه الاشتراطات ولاحقا تفتح
المدارس والجامعات ولانه اغلاقها هو قرار
نهائي
لانه ايديولوجيه تفكير طالبان لا تتقبل ان
تعلم الفتيات
هذه التصريحات ذاتيه لبعض مسؤولين
الطالبان
حياله اللباس وزي التعليمي للفتيات
والبنات ولكن الفرامل والقرارات الصارمه
تقول بان الفتيات والبنات يجب ان ينتظرنا
الاشعار والاشعار الثاني
والوقت غير محدد وبالتالي طالبا ليس لديها
لحد الان
اي اليه او خطه تعليميه او برامج لعوده
الفتيات والبنات الى الجامعات والمدارس
الابتدائيه كان من المتوقع ان تعود البنات
والفتيات في هذا العام الجديد واطلاله لدى
اطلاله فصل الربيع الى الجامعات والمدارس
ولكن لحد الان ليست هناك اي شارده من
الممكن ان نبني عليهم مستقبل الفتيات
والبنات
القرار الثاني تبقى نعم نعم اعتذر عن
المقاطعه ولكن انتهى وقتي عبد الله نادر
مراسل العربيه من كابول اشكرك على كل هذه
المعلومات
قال متحدث باسم الشرطه الباكستانيه ان
تفجيرا انتحاريا استهدافها حافله لنقل
الجنود اسفر عن مقتل تسعه من افراد الشرطه
في اقليم بلوشستان بجنوب غرب البلاد واضاف
المتحدث ان 15 فردا اخرين من الشرطه
اصيبوا في الهجوم وشهد الشرطه الباكستانيه
مذكرات توقيف الى رئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران خان لضمان مثوله امام المحكمه كما
وجهت وكاله التحقيقات الفيدراليه اتهامات
ضده في محكمه مكافحه الفساد التي اصدرت
الاسبوع الماضي اوامر اعتقال بعد ان فشل
خان في المثول امام المحكمه على الرغم من
الاستدعاءات المتكرره في اشاره الى غيابه
عن المحكمه قلخان ان المحاكم لم توفر
الامن الكافي
لا يوجد امن في المحاكم انهم يعلمون اني
تلقيت تهديدا لحياتي يستدعونني في قضايا
صغيره للغايه من محكمه الى اخرى
الفاصل
هي الاختيار مرشحهم لمنافسه اردوغان في
سباق اسيا
زعيم وفاجنر يحذر من نقص الذخيره في بخموت
ويحمل القاده الروس المسؤوليه في ماريوبول
حلاه تسمم جديده بين طالبات ايرانيات في
عشرات المدارس والسلطات تعتقل صحفيا كشف
الكارثه
الشرطه الباكستانيه تعلن مقتل تسعه من
افرادها واصابات خطيره في انفجار جنوب غرب
البلاد
وسط تصاعد التوترات مع بكين وزير الدفاع
التايواني يحذر من هجوم مفاجئ للجيش
الصيني
اهلا بكم من جديد في تركيا يجتمع قاده
تحالف الطاوله الخماسيه لاعلان زعيم حزب
الشعب الجمهوري والمعارضه التركيه كمال
اوغلو كمرشح مشترك وخريطه الطريق التي
سينفذونها في الفتره المقبله في وقت قال
فيه مسؤول في حزب الخير ان قائده الحزب
ميرال اكشنر التي اعلنت انسحابها من
التحالف الجمعه الماضيه قالت انها لن تنضم
الى اجتماع اليوم هذا وافاد بيان مشترك
لقاده الطاوله الخماسيه الذين عقدوا
اجتماعهم الاول بالامس ان التحالف سيواصل
تقريه دون التخلي عن اي شخص وان هدفه
الفوز وفي رد غير مباشر على اتهامات اكشنر
اشار البيان الى ان المشاورات والعقل
الجماعي والتسويه كانت ركائز عمليات صنع
القرار في تحالف الامه منذ تاسيسه وكانت
اكشنر زعيمه حزب الخير اتهمت جميع القاده
الخمسه بالتامري ضدها وضد حزبها اظهرت
لقطات كام المراقبه نشرت مؤخرا لحظه
انهيار مبنى سكني في زلزال قوي في ملاطيا
التركيه في الذي حصل طبعا في السادس من
فبراير الماضي حيث تسببت قوه الزلزال في
تفكك المبنى المكون من سبعه طوابق ما اسفر
عن مقتل 29 شخصا وفقا لمسؤلينا حكوميه
[موسيقى]
قلم مسؤولون امريكيون ان وزير الدفاع الذي
يزور الاردن في بدايه جوله بالشرق الاوسط
تشمل 3 دول يهدف الى التاكيد للحلفاء
الرئيسيين على الالتزام الامريكي بالبطاقه
على الرغم من تركيز واشنطن في الاونه
الاخيره على روسيا والصين وقال جنرال مشاه
البحريه الامريكيه المتقاعد فرانك ماكنزي
ان المنطقه مهمه للولايات المتحده جزئيا
بسبب دور الصين المتنامي واكد مسؤول
الدفاع الامريكي ان اوستن سيكون صريحا
تماما مع الزعماء الاسرائيليين بشان
مخاوفه من دائره العنف في الضفه الغربيه
والتشاور بشان الخطوه التي يمكن للزعماء
الاسرائيليين اتخاذها لاعاده الهدوء بشكل
فعال
رفضت الخارجيه الصينيه اتهامات مسؤولين
امريكيين عن قيام بيكين بعمليات التجسس
عبر الرافعات في الموانئ الامريكيه وقال
متحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه ان هذه
الاتهامات مفرطه الحساسيه ومضلله للشعب
الامريكي والمجتمع الدولي وكان مسؤولون
امريكيون اعربوا عن قلقهم من امكانيه
احتواء رافعات الحاويات الصينيه بالموانئ
الامريكيه على ادوات تجسس واجهزه استشعار
متطوره يمكنها تسجيل وتتبع مصدر ووجهه
الحاويات التي يستخدم الجيش الامريكي عددا
منها
قال وزير الدفاع التايواني تشيو
على ان الجزيره يجب ان تتاهب هذا العام
تحسبا لاي دخول مفاجئ للجيش الصيني في
مناطق قريبه من الاراضي الاراضي
التايوانيه وسط تصاعد التوترات العسكريه
عبر مضيق تايوان وزير الدفاع اوضح ايضا ان
الصين قد توجد اعذارا مختلفه لدخولها الى
المناطق القريبه من المجال الجوي والبحري
الاقليميه لتايوان
تطارد السلطات الموريتانيه سجناء من
مقاتلي تنظيم القاعده بعد ان فروا من سجن
وسطا وعكشوط كانوا ادينوا قبل عشر سنوات
بالتورط فيها هجمات ارهابيه ويوصف عناصر
القاعده الفاريين بالخاطرين جدا يذكر ان
اثنين من السجناء الهاربين شاركوا فيها
هجمات على ثقنات للجيش الموريتاني خلال
فتره الارهاب والمواجهه مع التنظيم بين
2005 و211
اتخذ الممثل الكوميدي كريستراك من تلقيه
صفعه من النجم والسميث خلال حفل الاوسكار
العام الماضي ماده للسخريه في حلقه
كوميديه خاصه عرضت على الهواء مباشره على
منصه نتفليكس خاضتها هذه المنصه لاول مره
واكد فيها انه لم يشاهد الفيلم الاخير
لويل سميث الى ان سميث ضرب فيه بكثره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
صفعه الاوسكار اوسكريه ما تزال تطن في اذن
التاريخ وكذلك الممثل الكوميدي كريس روك
هنا قرر الروك ان يفك اللعنه الصفعه
بطريقته على منصه نتفليكس التي ضربت
عصفورين بحجر واحد
باعتبارها تجرب البث المباشر لحلقه
كوميديه خاصه خرج فيها روك عن صمته لاول
مره منذ عام
قائلا انه تلذذ برؤيه النجم والسميث يتلقى
الضربات في فيلمه الاخير ايمان
مؤكدا انه شاهد الفيلم فقط ليشفى غنيله من
سميث وفي كل مقطع يشجع على ضربه كان يقول
اضربه مره ثانيه وثمه مكان لم تضربه فيه
[تصفيق]
حيث لا يزال الجدل المستمرا حول قضيه
تطبيق هود بول وضحاياه من الالاف المصريين
الذين خسروا مدخرات تقدر بمليارات
الجنيهات التفاصيل في التقرير لزميل احمد
عمر قاسم يعمل كعامل توصيل على دراجته
الناريه واحد من مئات الالاف من الذين
وقعوا ضحيه تطبيق هاك بول تلك المنصه التي
نجحت في الاستيلاء على سته مليارات جنيه
من مدخرات المصريين منذ انشائها منذ اكثر
من سته شهور قبل ان يتم اغلاقها ليتحول
حلم الثروه الى كابوس وعنوان لاشهر عمليه
نصب الكتروني انا رجل بطالب بفلوسي تمام
ان فلوسي ترجع لي ان انا يعني راجل شغال
على الله في يوميتي ما تجازيش ان انا اقعد
اسدد في الفلوس دي كلها اللي انا خسرتها
دي اسماء التي تعمل في مجال الهندسه كانت
ضحيه اخرى فالمنصه اوهمت عملائها بانها
تمتلك ماكينات للتعدين الخاص بالعملات
الرقميه ونجحت فعلا في توفير ارباح لفتره
قصيره انا مبلغي كان 31
في ناس تانيه مليون ونص وكده فالمبالغ مش
سهله وواحده وتلاتين الف برضو احنا مش
جايبينها بسهوله يعني مش لاقيينهم في
الارض فهي الفكره احنا عاوزين حقنا يجي
فلوسنا بقى ترجع يتقبض عليهم كلهم ده اهم
حاجه حقنا يجي قوته الامن نجحت في القبض
على مجموعه من المتهمين اغلب الاموال تم
تحويلها للخارج بالعملات الاجنبيه النيابه
العامه امرت بفتح تحقيق موسع في القضيه قد
تحيل النيابه المتهمين الى محكمه بتهمه
الجنايات بتهمه توظيف الاموال وقد تحلهم
فقط الى محكمه الجنح
بجنحه النصب على المجني عليه
وايضا التهمه الثالثه
وهيئه استخدام مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
متخصصون في مجال التقنيه اكدوا استحاله
تمكن الحكومه واجهزتها في منع هذا النوع
من التطبيقات والمنصات التي تنتشر بشكل
كبير ده لازم يتم من خلال المنصه بالاتفاق
مع المنصه فالدوله تقدر تمنع ولكن لما
تعرف التطبيق بيعمل ايه فتطبيقات دي كل
يوم فالحاله الوحيد فيها هو الوعي بتاع
الشخص ما فيش حاجه اسمها هتكسب من الهواء
ولا فلوس مضاعفه من مجرد تعدين او من
عملات بحطها وارجع اخد من وراها مكسبول
سينضم الى قائمه عمليات النصب الشهيره
والتي تنجح اغلبها في الاستيلاء على اموال
المصريين الذين يخدعون باوهام الثراء
السريع احمد عثمان العربيه القاهره
افدت تقارير صحفيه عن طريقها الامير هاري
وزوجته ميغن ماركل دعوه لحضور احتفال
تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث اكدت التقارير
ان الامير هاري وزوجته ميغن اللذين انسحب
من العائله الملكيه البريطانيه تلقيا
مراسلات عبر البريد الالكتروني بدعوى
للحضور الا انهما لم يقرروا بعد اذا كان
سيحضران احتفال تتويج الملك تشارلز في
مايو المقبل
الى العناوين
زعيم وفاجنر يحذر من نقص الذخيره في بخمه
ويحمل القاده الروس المسؤوليه في ماريوبول
حالات تسمم جديده بين طالبات ايرانيات في
عشرات المدارس والسلطات تعتقل صحفيا كشف
الكارثه
الشرطه الباكستانيه تعلن مقتل تسعه من
افرادها واصابات خطيره في انفجار جنوب غرب
البلاد
وسط تصاعد التوترات مع بيكين وزير الدفاع
التايواني يحذر منه هجوم مفاجئ للجيش
الصيني
العربيه للمزيد من الاخبار والتحليلات الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]